[Music]
hello and welcome to sophie co
visionaries me sophie shepard nazi
well it's surrounded by all sorts of
ideas and we think
it's us producing and using them but
what if it's
them using us well we talk about memes
with dr
susan blackmore psychologist broadcaster
and visiting professor at the university
of plymouth
dr susan blackmore psychologist
broadcaster and visiting professor at
the university of plymouth it's really
great to have you with us today
welcome thank you very much this should
be fun
i hope i'm sure it will be fun because
you've done a lot
of works on means and the role in human
evolution
so let's clarify this a bit right what
exactly does it mean because
when i think meme i think like funny cat
pictures from the internet and that's
probably what most of the
people that are my audience think right
you mean something
slightly different by meme could you
give a brief definition
yeah yes or no internet memes um
are one category of memes it's not that
there's something different
there are only one category it actually
everything in our culture that we pass
from person to person is memes
so let me explain how the idea began it
was
in 1976 long before the internet let
alone
silly cat pictures in richard dawkins
best-selling book the selfish gene
and what that book was about was what he
called
universal darwinism this is the idea
that
really darwin's brilliant insight
doesn't just apply to genes it applies
it would apply to life on any planet
anywhere
it's basically a kind of three-step
algorithm so if you think about how
natural selection works
you have some kind of information which
could be genes information
it has to be copied it has to be copied
with variations
and then there has to be selection so
that most of those variants
are killed off so if you take rabbits
for example each rabbit has like loads
of babies and most of them die
so the ones that survive pass on
whatever helped them survive
running fast or eating quicker or
whatever it might be
that's how it works with jeans but the
principle is general
so at the end of the book richard
dawkins wanted to say
i'm this book although it's about
selfish genes
it's about any information that is
copied that way
and he called those replicators okay so
jeans are replicators
and he said are there any other
replicators on this planet
yes look everything we pass from person
to person we're copying stories
songs financial institutions scientific
theories
all these things are copied from person
to person we vary them by forgetting or
changing them as we pass them on then
most of them
don't get copied so it is a darwinian
process
happening on culture we need a name for
the new replicator
i want something that sounds a bit like
gene um i'll call them memes
which literally comes from the greek my
meme which means that which is copied or
that which is imitated
so memes are everything we imitate from
person to person in our culture
and internet memes are just one example
just to be even more precise can you
give me like
like few really obvious examples and
maybe less obvious examples of what a
meme
is concrete every word
that we are using in this conversation
is a meme
because you didn't invent you might have
invented a new word i think i've
invented a couple of new words but
you know mostly um our language we
we learnt it from other people when we
were little
or later on and all those words are all
memes
then they are combined in different
combinations to make new sentences and
then the sentences into stories
and then they are all copied and varied
so that's a kind of
fundamental um type of meme
they memes clumped together into mean
plexes so complexes of co-adapted memes
that go together so religions you might
not think of a religion like
islam or christianity as being a meme
but it is it's a big complex of memes
passed on with all these rules and
regulations to make sure it's tightly
passed on and that it gets into new
brains
so that's that's an area i'm
particularly interested in
we're going to talk about religion
actually i have a few questions about
that
um can something like fashion
uh be a meme or a ruler or a tradition
yeah yeah see i thought when i did my
hair about 30 years ago it's all faded
now with code
covid but you know i thought everyone's
going to copy me that everyone will want
pink and blue hair
it didn't really work as a meme and they
any you know i didn't fill the world
with it but it would have been
i'm not very fashionable person but if
you go around you will probably notice
which kinds of jeans are in this year
and that is copying people see other
people
oh i really fancy those jeans with all
those ripped bits or whatever's
fashionable now i wouldn't know
um and um and they think oh i'm going to
buy some of those
and so more of those ones are made and
fewer of the ones that
don't take people's you know suddenly
attempt to get their attention
so yes old fashions definitely richard
dawkins gave the example of um
baseball caps worn backwards which was a
craze then when he was
when he invented the term meme yes
definitely fashions count yes
you might think everything is a meme
then you get really confused
but if you want to know whether
something that you're thinking about is
a meme or not think
is it has it been copied did i get it
for some from somebody else
so for example if you learn to ride a
skateboard
or yeah let's say a skateboard um the
idea of the skateboard and the
skateboard itself has been copied in
factories and copied by people and so on
the idea but the skill you need
to balance on the thing and not fall off
well you fall off and then you
learn better that you can't pass on
that's something you have to learn for
yourself so that
isn't a meme the same with learning to
drive a car or all the physical skills
that
that we acquire because you have to
learn them for yourself
so they are not means right so meme is a
selfish information that strives to be
copied
whenever it can does a meme replicate
itself like a virus in this sense
well yes it's a very good question
because it doesn't replicate itself in a
vacuum
like i mean genes in order to replicate
themselves need messenger rna and all
the chemistry and all that
memes need a human we might get on to
technological memes
at some point but ordinary memes need a
human
who can think and speak or write or in
some way communicate
demonstrate things um to other people
so um that that's what makes them i mean
that ability
to be copied so yes in a sense they're
copying themselves
when you say they strive do you have to
be a bit careful about that
obviously memes are just bits of
information like in words coming out of
my mouth
how can they strive what to say they
strive
really means is if they can get copied
they will
which is important because you have to
stop them if they can and you don't want
them to
so if they can get copied they will and
so that looks like that looks like
striving and we can call it striving
all right so memes like cells you're
saying engage in darwinian race for
carriers for our reigns and only the
fittest meme survives that's what i find
really interesting
how do we know that there is an
evolutionary drive inherent in
information like
we know there is such a drive inherent
in our species or any other species
because it's been
tested and proved biologically time and
again how can you
test meme theory uh
well it's really difficult which is why
um there isn't a great science of
mimetics there is some science of
meticulous but not a huge amount
uh given that we are now how long since
um you know it's 45 years or something
um
so why not because it is difficult
but there is now fairly recently a
thriving science of cultural evolution
which takes the idea that culture is
evolving which is really not that
um surprising or controversial
that it's evolving in a kind of loose
sense although some people object even
to that idea
mimetics goes a bit further than other
theories in
the more conventional types of cultural
evolution theory
in calling it selfish replicators so the
difference really
between these different ways of
approaching the evolution of culture
is a lot of biologists will say yeah but
ultimately what happens in culture comes
back to the genes
the e.o wilson a long time ago made a
famous claim
a famous biologist made a famous claim
that
um the genes will always keep culture on
a leash
and that remains true for many
biologists and think they think of
culture as therefore ultimately pulled
back by the genes it's got to be good
for us
and okay it'll make mistakes sometimes
but basically it's controlled by what's
good for us
whereas mimetic says no the information
is selfish
these memes are going to get themselves
copied however they can
and we humans then have to try to choose
the ones which
which which are good for us uh which
help us or help our society or
make us happier or something but we're
not terribly good at it
and the selfish memes are constantly
just doing their thing
and trying to use our brains to copy
them and when you look at what's
happening
and what's happened since the concept of
meme was invented
well we can see the kind of acceleration
you expect with evolutionary processes
so uh if you think about the four and a
half billion years of the planet's
existence
it was a very very long time before it
got
cells at all and then when the cells got
eukaryotes
excuse me more like like bacteria it was
very very slow and it speeded up and
speeded up
it's not it's not a unitary thing but
speed it up
and that's precisely what's happening as
the memes
um as it becomes more variation
more different stories more
communication across the world because
of modern technology
all of these things allow there's more
variation there's more pressure for
selection
so there's more um happening and change
going on
so that's that that's the mimetic view
and that's what we have to
have to um to test against other
theories um
i want to talk about this interesting
distinction uh when you say the fittest
of memes survive
but not not necessarily the best how
would you describe
or measure the fittest
um or how would you measure a goodness
of a meme
right you're you're right hitting the
very important questions here
so fitness for a meme is
how easy easy it finds itself to get
copied
and this you can use therefore and
people do i'm no mathematician but other
people
do the kind of mathematical modeling and
so on taking the methods from biology
to look at fitness landscapes and um
which ones thrive and which don't and
then the psychology which i'm more
involved in as a psychologist you ask
well
does this meme succeed because it just
grabs your attention and takes you away
from things that
would would be better for you is it
succeed because actually it's very
useful
questions something like tick tock it's
not neces it doesn't necessarily have
like
any value to it like for humanity but
it's
it's like a very fast replicating thing
yeah and what it's doing and it does is
particularly with
with younger people and certain groups
of people it grabs your attention
because you've only got a very short
time you think i've got to respond now
you don't want to miss it it's it's it's
um
it's playing on all the biological so
we start as a biological organism a
social species
um and then we've got language and
everything else but we've got those
basic
you know i want to be in here i want to
be known about
i want to be popular i want people to
notice me
and these memes are playing on all those
basic
human tendencies and so tick-tock is a
very good example which is
i think quite harmful for a lot of
people because it
simply keeps taking them away from being
able to concentrate on something that
really they might enjoy more or they
might learn more from or might in many
ways be better
but just to go back to really the
framework of your question
when we take any meme or meanplex we can
say
is it fit that's in its own terms is it
good or bad from a genetic point of view
in other words
keeping people alive and having
offspring they might pass them on to and
all that
or is it good for us as individual
people to make us
happier or more skillful or something
like that
is it good or bad for whole societies
and those you know it's very complicated
because then you've got four
different kind of warring beasts
with their own interests genes means
human individuals and society all have
different interests
and the memes are just information you
know playing around in this
complicated sphere and getting copied
when they can susan we're going to take
a short break right now when we're back
we'll continue
talking to psychologist broadcaster
visiting professor at the university of
plymouth dr
susan blackmore talking about memes stay
with us
[Music]
and we're back with dr susan blackmore
psychologist broadcaster
visiting professor at the university of
plymouth susan
those memes that do survive the test of
time i mean in my opinion it will be
automatically the most useful for human
evolution
they're for good right like i know
you're not a big fan of religion
that's where we're getting to it and you
say religion is not necessarily the most
benevolent of memes
but i mean it had its use when it
appeared right it is still
it still has used among those who
practice it giving them a sense of i
don't know tradition
purpose fulfillment community
what's so about what is it that you
don't like
about religion in terms of it being a
meme
well let's start from this point that um
it must have been useful at some point i
think by and large we humans are
meme machines we're the copying
selecting varying machines
we're mean machines trying all the time
to choose
as you say to choose the things that are
good for us all good for our biology
interestingly that's true of many things
but it's particularly true of of the
the major faiths they started off
very biologically based so you find
in um in christianity and judaism in
islam
you find you know the men are in charge
the women are chattels and objects to be
passed from one to the other
it starts with that which is which is in
our inherent in our basic biology as the
kind of species we are
so you start with that and build the
religions on that
now that's very good from a gene's point
of view and it's still
true today that orthodox jews have
something like i haven't seen the latest
figures but something like on average
uh eight children per woman um
christians have somewhere between two
and three
um orthodox extreme
islam have more and atheists have below
replacement level
so you know if you're relying on
what's called vertical transmission
parents to children parents to children
parents down the things
that's what religions are very good at
and that
plays into the biology but
over time and this is the implication of
your question over time they escape
now if you look at something like the um
declaration of universal human rights
that goes
right against those kind of basic
biological things and instead of giving
the power to the genes controlled
largely by
men um they give power to
every individual we are all of equal
value and we should all have human
rights and that is i think an
understandable progression
of the memes as it were extricating
themselves
from this firm connection to
biological reproduction just to continue
with this analogy between a meme and a
virus
let's assume there are good and bad
memes right
vaccines stop viruses from spreading
how do you stop a bad meme from
spreading is it
even possible well we're trying to do it
all the time aren't we
the current arguments going on about
social media
and whether um governments can intervene
and force social media to take down
you know anti-vaxxed stuff all kinds of
conspiracy theories
qr what's it called um um
the the conspiracy theories going around
the states that the q anon
these kinds of things they are attempts
to manipulate the
mimosa with greater or lesser
um effectiveness of course we're always
trying
you know we've hit on this with your
questions and some of my answers
several times already this the
difference in the interest between the
memes
whose only interest is to get copied and
us and our societies
you know when i look around it seems
like everything let it be like food or a
piece of furniture clothes music has
been
replicated and transformed from
something that has already existed
what i want to say is that i mean we
essentially live
in the world of memes right does
anything original
even exist there are the ideas that we
think
are ours um that we think we first come
up with
essentially ours or is everything them
that i'm thinking is a meme
right well first of all i i did mention
earlier that
and this applies to your thoughts as
well you asked is everything you're
thinking a meme
well if you come up with a new thought
that's never been had before well it's
not a meme yet until you transmit it to
somebody else and then it becomes a meme
but also if you think let's say imagine
last time you were by
a lake side or the sea you have
you can conjure up a vivid image of that
you can't transmit that to anybody else
that's i mean this comes into the
problem of consciousness which is
something else i work on an awful lot
you know that
is private to you it's your visual
memory is able to
evoke those kinds of images in your
brain um
and you're able to remember that scene
or remember the face of someone you
loved or whatever it is you can't
transmit those things there's an awful
lot goes on in your mind that is not
mimetic
at all um on then to the other part of
your question
um is there anything novel well it's
exactly the same as biology
if you ask has there ever been anything
novel in biology well
there weren't elephants at some point
and now there are there weren't human
beings at some point and now there are
but you can traces the power of
evolutionary theory of course
you can trace it back right the way down
you know to the origins of life
on this planet and it is all because
of the darwinian evolutionary algorithm
because information has been copied so
through those billions of years we have
this amazing
diversity of biology which we are
threatening but nevertheless we do
and it's exactly the same with memes our
cultures are vibrant
changing all the time but everything you
say and right everything in our
conversation
is new there are probably sentences that
each of us has said
in the last 20 minutes which has never
been said before a lot of it will have
been said before but we may have some
sentence that's
peculiar to this morning um and to uh
who we are
and that's a brand new meme that
somebody may go and repeat they probably
won't but they might
um and so novelty comes about by
recombination
and that's the same with genetics a lot
of the
some in genes some comes about by
mutation
but but the majority at least in in
sexual species
comes about by recombining old genes
into new new or
new order so that's the same with means
it recombination is really what it's all
about
and it's going faster and faster
now in the present we're not only
producing memes like in the examples
you've described but also
technological memes that are teams right
teams i've started to calling them
because people thought i was talking
about football or something when i
called them teams in my ted talk
um so i've turned it into dreams from
sort of trying screaming sweetie
you know i'm sorry it's confusing i i'd
love to have got a better word
i did put an advert in well little
request in new scientist magazine
for people to suggest a good name for
the new technological um
or cyber um electronic um memes
and like they came up with 21 different
names and nobody agreed and uh so it's
streams
okay streams so uh let me ask you this
are you saying that
dreams reproduce themselves and it's not
humans invading technology it's
technology replicating itself
through us i mean could you explain why
your view gives humanity
this like passive role of replicators of
information instead of
a conventional view of humanity as
creators of information
well it just drops out of the whole meme
theory it's not that we're passive
but it's it's that our arrogance and so
often science doesn't it takes us down a
peg or two from you know we're the
center of the universe and all that you
know we're
constantly being taken down we have this
feeling that we have
free will and that we can use our free
will to design amazing new technology
and
and that we're in charge well of course
we in a sense it was humans who designed
the first computers and so on so on
but the mimetic way of looking at that
is to say well people are always
inventing new things they're recombining
old ideas
and then there's a competition for those
to be adopted
you think of all the startups that have
gone by the board
and the ones that succeeded because they
were doing a job that we wanted or
because they attracted our attention or
because they made us feel good whatever
the reasons were
certain technologies um progressed to
the point where we all
now have or almost all of us have very
clever phones
in our pockets um and we just think well
humans invented those
but why we have those is a result of the
huge competition
that went on now what gets to me is this
um and i did talk about this in in my
ted lecture
which is i kept worrying is there
something new going on
or are all this stuff that we're sending
through our computers and phones and
servers and everything
is that just should we just call that
memes is it more memes
but it was troubling me there's
something different about it
and the conclusion i came to was this if
you start with genes
then the the the the animals us that the
genes made
um but started a new process of
imitating
and varying and selecting and that was
memes and language and all of
this culture it could be another step
in which these these memes us with our
memes
construct some kind of new thing that is
capable of imitating
um copying varying and selecting or
doing it itself that would then be a
third replicator
gene's meme streams when would we say
that's happened
and i decided this was a little over 10
years ago now
that there really would be a new
replicator if the machinery itself was
doing all the hard work if
if if we're kind of sitting here
enjoying it maybe
but the copying varying selecting are
being done
by the machinery now that maybe 10 years
ago it was pretty touch and go but now
it's
quite clear i mean all the all the
technology the search engines the
the the sales pitches the amazons and
what have you
they are all doing they're taking
information they're copying it they're
varying it they're putting it together
into
a new form just for you because they've
gathered all the information about you
and they think all
right she'll buy this they're not humans
thinking that it's just
it's just software doing it so it seems
to me there is already a third
replicator on this planet and
we're not realizing it we still think
we're in charge we still
and people still think about artificial
intelligence as
oh it's going to be in a in a robot that
might attack us or something of that
kind
but that's not what's interesting me i'm
thinking well out there in cyberspace
is going to be happening what happens in
in biology and in mimetics
things club together and make mean
plexes team
sheen plexus they make kind of organism
like organisms equivalent of with
membranes with
wanting to survive and so on and we
really ought to see
what's happening out there because it's
not under our control
that's that's where this is where it
seems to lead me
and i'm trying to understand it it's a
topic like
a conversation for a whole other program
i'm sorry i get carried away yeah i
really no but it's been so
so so wonderful speaking to you it's
it's really interesting
i really appreciate you did this for us
and i hope that we get together again to
talk about
the last point you've made all right
let's let's do that one day i'd enjoy
that very much
thank you so much sue thank you thank
you for all your questions
thank you thank you thank you bye
[Music]
you